dès ce matin on a vraiment souhaité
vous recevoir avant de conclure
cette mission sur la simplification
on partage évidemment
aussi bien gouvernement que à notre
délégation le souci de simplifier une
façon habituelle mais ça méritait qu'on
s'empare de du sujet pour essayer
d'aller un petit peu plus loin et on
verra tout à l'heure
dans les interventions de nos
rapporteurs le travail qui a été qui a
été conduit et donc on souhaitait que
vous soyez associés un petit peu en
amont avant de conclure tout ça
alors mes chers collègues
[Musique]
salut et je vous rappelle que nous
accueillons ce matin madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre délégué chargé des
petits témoignages entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
pour une audition qui vient clore les
travaux de la mission d'information de
notre
délégation sur le thème de la
simplification des normes applicables
aux entreprises
madame la ministre le Sénat discutera la
semaine prochaine du projet de loi sur
l'industrie verte qui propose notamment
d'alléger certaines procédures
administratives pour accélérer le
déploiement d'implantation industrielle
d'intérêt national majeur relevant du
champ de l'industrie verte c'est un
premier petit pas mais la délégation
d'entreprise aimerait qu'un pas géant
soit franchi comme le réclame toutes les
entreprises que nous rencontrons sur le
terrain pour alléger le fardeau normatif
qui représente 60 milliards d'euros soit
3% de PIB
dans le contexte d'une concurrence
mondiale
exacerbait cet allégement permettrait
pourtant aux entreprises françaises
d'améliorer considérablement leurs
compétitivité ce qui contribuerait à
diminuer à déficit commercial abyssal à
créer de l'emploi à portée des recettes
fiscales supplémentaires à l'état et aux
collectivités locales les normes pèsent
davantage sur les PME
que sur les grandes entreprises qui
disposent des moyens de gérer la
complexité administrative que ce soit en
matière fiscale ou économique
contrairement la France nos principaux
partenaires européens ont intégré ce
fardeau et mis en place des politiques
publiques de long terme c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est de voir comment font
mieux que nous certains autres
d'une façon consensuelle et structurelle
visant à réduire la charge
administrative pesant sur leurs
entreprises ces politiques ont généré de
substantiels économiques ce chiffrant à
plusieurs milliards d'euros par an en
améliorant la compétitivité leurs
entreprises pourquoi notre pays n'a-t-il
pas pu malgré une prise de conscience
précoce du problème au plus haut niveau
administratif et politique et plusieurs
tentatives réduire le fardeau
administratif pesant sur les entreprises
de manière significative et pérenne
les rapporteurs de ce rapport
d'information mes collègues Olivier
rickmann Jean-Pierre Moga et Gilbert Luc
de vinaz qui sont qui vous font face
mais c'est juste une facture
auront tout à l'heure l'opportunité ne
vous interroger sur la manière dont le
gouvernement a mener une politique de
simplification depuis 2017 et pour
savoir si le projet de loi industrielle
correspond à une prise de conscience de
nécessité absolue d'alléger le phare de
l'administratif qui pèse sur les
entreprises et singulièrement les plus
petites d'entre elles sont les
propositions du gouvernement pour
diminuer structurellement la complexité
normative applicable aux entreprises
précises que pour réaliser ce rapport
d'information outre des déplacements en
Europe ou des visioconférence avec la
Suisse l'Allemagne la délégation des
entreprises a ouvert une consultation à
laquelle ont répondu près de 800
entreprises
qui estime à 90% que les normes ne sont
pas adaptées à toutes les situations
à 84% qu'elles ne sont pas faciles à
comprendre et ça ça nous interpelle
le gouvernement sûrement mais les
législateurs aussi que nous sommes et à
82 je rappelle le chiffre 94% qu'elles
ne sont pas faciles à comprendre et 82%
qu'elle ne s'accompagne pas d'une
information adéquate
et enfin elles sont 80% les entreprises
à attendre que l'administration les
accompagne davantage et les conseils
mieux
ça c'est une demande aussi récurrente
sur le changement d'attitude
d'administration de transformer le
contrôle plutôt en accompagnement même
s'il faut contrôler on est bien
conscient madame la ministre évidemment
tout d'abord la parole pour un propos
liminaire d'une durée de 20 minutes
environ puis les trois rapporteurs de la
mission vous poseront leurs questions
ainsi que l'ensemble de nos collègues
qui devront s'arrêter des questions au
plus tard à 10 heures messieurs
monsieur le Président babary
messieurs les Cora porteurs Moga rietman
et devinez d'abord je tiens à m'excuser
puisque la ponctualité est une politesse
importante de la dizaine de minutes de
retard
que mon expression et mon nez bouché
justifie puisque j'ai l'honneur d'avoir
une fille malade et qui m'a en plus
contaminée mais je tiens à m'excuser
pour ce léger retard qui n'est pas lié à
ma volonté
je vous remercie déjà de m'avoir proposé
cet échange devant la délégation aux
entreprises du Sénat dans le cadre de
vos travaux que j'en profite pour saluer
parce que ce sont des travaux qui sont
inspirants et et qui nous nourrissent
d'ailleurs au ministère en charge des
PME du Commerce de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme notamment sur la simplification
des règles et des normes applicables aux
entreprises conduit par les
corps-à-porteurs je me réjouis d'autant
plus de participer à vos travaux que ce
sujet est évidemment au cœur de mon
portefeuille ministériel
et oserais-je vous dire oui je vais oser
plus largement au cœur de mon engagement
politique
je viens des PME j'ai même créé ma
propre TPE je ne vis pas la
simplification comme un impératif
exogène je vis la simplification comme
un impératif absolu
et je sais combien nous avons encore du
chemin à parcourir ayant été moi-même
indépendantes chef de ma petite
entreprise puis 6 années entre le
Parlement et Bercy n'ont absolument rien
changé à mon constat quand on parle de
réglementation pour les entreprises
je me souviens toujours de cette époque
quand chaque courrier administratif même
le plus anodin comme nombre de nos
entrepreneurs me mettaient dans un état
de panique ou d'angoisse
trop longtemps la simplification des
normes est restée un vœu pieux et ça
n'est pas à des sénateurs que je vais la
prendre sachant que c'est au Sénat que
nous devons vous le savez mieux que moi
les premières grandes lois de nettoyage
entre guillemets de mise à jour et de
coordination d'un grand nombre de
législations on a souvent eu tendance
dans notre pays à empiler les normes
vous le savez aussi à les allonger aller
sur transposer à les complexifier et
parfois les trains de simplifications
ont manqué leurs coût si je peux me
permettre cette expression en coupant un
wagon sans se rendre compte qu'il
s'agissait de la locomotive au moins ces
trains avaient-ils la vertu d'exister
chacun aura sûrement en tête des
simplifications qui sont restées en gare
moi aussi je vous rassure la constante
derrière ces pratiques c'est qu'on a
souvent régulé sens interroger
réellement sur l'impact réel de la norme
en particulier pour les entreprises je
pense que ça a aujourd'hui profondément
changé
du moins c'est ton train profondément de
changer principalement pour trois
raisons d'abord je partage avec vous un
état d'esprit j'ai le sentiment que de
l'Assemblée au Sénat mais aussi à Bercy
et au sein du gouvernement nous avons
largement pris conscience du problème
les travaux du Parlement et notamment
ceux de votre délégation ont permis de
rendre systématique la question de la
portée de la norme pour ceux qui
l'utiliseront demain
ce n'est donc pas et c'est tant mieux
aujourd'hui une direction ou un bureau
qui comme d'ailleurs à l'époque peut
être chargé de la simplification mais
c'est bel et bien l'ensemble de
l'administration mais aussi du pouvoir
exécutif qui doit prendre en compte dans
chaque proposition dans chaque projet de
loi dans chaque avancée normative ce
besoin d'alléger et de simplifier les
normes autant que faire ce peu chacune
dans leur champ de compétences la
deuxième raison
réside aussi que dans le fait que nous
avons je crois je dis bien nous
collectivement gouvernement mais surtout
le Parlement nous avons beaucoup ça
n'est que mon sentiment mais je le
partage avec vous développer quand même
la culture du moins la pratique de la
co-construction normative
j'ai en tête des exemples très concrets
je pense là en échangeant devant vous
par exemple l'ordonnance des professions
libérales qui a été publiée il y a
maintenant quelques mois cette
ordonnance au service des professions
libérales qui est dense a été vraiment
rédigée avec l'ensemble des partis
prenantes avec l'ensemble des publics
concernés ça aussi été le cas dans la
loi pacte que j'ai porté en 2018 lorsque
nous avions additionné pas moins de 600
entreprises et institutions et nous
avions même au-delà de l'audition confié
en termes de méthode les reines des des
chapitres à un parlementaire dont
j'étais à l'époque avec un chef
d'entreprise donc dès le démarrage de la
construction de la loi pacte c'est aussi
été le cas pour le projet de loi
industrie vert dont nous aurons le
plaisir de parler l'intégration dès le
début d'entrepreneur très opérationnel
fait qu'un certain nombre de normes sont
co-construites ou supprimer si
inutile dès le début
enfin je crois qu'on simplifie plus de
manière isolée c'est le pendant du point
2 la simplification devient inhérente à
un nouveau projet de loi parce qu'on a
vu que simplifier par petites touches
dans un projet de loi peut détruire la
cohérence d'un grand nombre d'autres
textes nous préférons désormais insérer
des mesures de simplification dans les
textes même la loi ISOC de 2018 illustre
ce principe au même titre que la loi
industrie verte récemment présentée par
le Président de la République et qui fut
comme je voulais rappeler construit
grâce au travail préparatoire de ces
pilotes des parlementaires des élus
locaux et des chefs d'entreprise dans
les quatre piliers de ce projet loi
industriels dont nous parlerons ensemble
dont vous devez d'ailleurs bientôt
commencer l'examen nous en comptons
d'ailleurs un qui s'intitule faciliter
et qui vise par exemple un raccourcir
drastiquement enfin des délais pour
répondre à des attentes formulées par
les entreprises j'accorde un intérêt
d'autant plus fort à ce sujet qu'il est
largement consensuel ce qui n'est pas si
courant aujourd'hui
et que si les correctement traités il
peut être source de croissance de
compétitivité d'emplois donner un cas
juridique et essentiel mais ça
complexité ne peut pas venir paralysée
l'entrepreneur simplifier la vie de
l'entrepreneur c'est donc un objectif
qui nous anime dans notre action
quotidienne
c'est le hasard du calendrier mais je le
partage avec vous j'étais hier à
Bruxelles où j'étais
speaker où j'intervenais en introduction
d'un colloque de deux jours
qui s'appelle business days et qui est
porté notamment par le groupe Run you
pour faire le point sur l'ensemble des
pratiques de simplification et des
politiques publiques de soutien aux PME
un ancien Premier ministre le disait
mieux que moi mais quand on j'ai jamais
la bonne formule là dessus mais quand on
se regarde on s'inquiète quand on se
compare on se rassure je tiens à vous
dire que c'était intéressant puisque
nous parlions de simplification et le
programme dites-le nous une fois que
vous connaissez qui a été impulsé dans
l'ensemble des pays européens et
considéré comme étant mené de façon
assez exemplaire chez nous en France
donc j'ai été beaucoup d'interroger sur
dites le nous une fois notamment par des
acteurs économiques et des
parlementaires d'Europe de l'Est ou
d'Europe du Nord pour savoir comment
nous avions déployé ce principe dites-le
nous une fois qui est plutôt bien mené
dans notre pays pour terminer que ce
soit la mise en place du guichet unique
dont on aura je n'en doute pas
l'occasion d'en parler de parler et vous
connaissez ma franchise à cet endroit je
n'ai pas changé
que ce soit la déclaration sociale
numérique l'agglomération des registres
chacun de ces chantiers a été réfléchi
et construit pour que
l'auto-entrepreneur ou le dirigeant de
PME ne perdent pas de temps à se
demander où est-ce qu'il doit déclarer
sa nouvelle activité ou s'il faut
signaler les vacances de son comptable
moi-même dans le cas de mon action
ministérielle je travaille à fluidifier
le dialogue entre pouvoirs publics et
acteur privé afin que nous n'utilisions
plus le terme
de bureaucratie
ou red tape comme on disait hier à
Bruxelles
au service des citoyens des usagers et
des acteurs le problème de la
bureaucratie en réalité messieurs les
sénateurs vous le savez ça n'est pas que
les bureaux puissent avoir du pouvoir
c'est quand ils sont les seuls à en
avoir ou les seuls à le savoir je vais
donc très heureuse sincèrement que nous
puissions avoir ce temps d'échange
j'ajouterai un dernier point
je sais pas si on aura le temps d'en
parler mais c'est une ouverture
peut-être pour la rentrée puisque
j'apprécie beaucoup les échanges avec
votre délégation
je crois aussi peut-être pas sur les
normes du quotidien au plan national
mais je crois aussi qu'il y a tout un
débat et je me tiens à votre disposition
pour peut-être le nourrir dans les
prochains mois sur les normes à venir
issus de l'Europe que ce soit ces SRD
que ce soit le devoir de vigilance des
normes qui en matière de seuil de
périmètre vont frôler rapprocher voir
intégrer nos PME
et des normes
dont je pense qu'il est majeur de de
considérer que
je crois pas que la norme
ipso facto soit mauvaise
je crois que il est des normes parce que
le débat que nous avions hier c'était
est-ce que les normes ou la bureaucratie
est un bordel un fardeau
à l'aune des échanges que j'ai pu avoir
pendant des heures hier à Bruxelles et
pensant à vous hier je me disais que
c'était intéressant peut-être de
partager avec vous messieurs les Cora
porteurs car certains nombre de normes
notamment je suis prêt National sont en
train d'être créés et déployés au plan
européen et que c'est énorme sont aussi
peut-être les marqueurs
d'une pratique d'un capitalisme européen
soutenable
il est des normes qui pèsent il est des
normes je crois qu'ils pourront porter
mais qui pourront porter au sens positif
du terme
et je pense en tout cas pour ma part en
tant que mini je n'ai pas une acception
générique de la norme comme étant un
fardeau il est un certain nombre de
normes qui en sont il est aussi des
normes qui nous porteront je suis pas
sûr qu'en 1h malheureusement c'est un
débat assez prévenant qu'on pourra
l'aborder mais sachez que je suis
vraiment à votre disposition peut-être
après les congés d'été si vous souhaitez
qu'on ait un peu un débat sur ces sujets
pour le dire de façon très simple et un
peu et vous pardonnerez ma trivialité ne
mettons pas toutes les normes dans le
même sac certaines sont délétères mais
d'autres sont porteuses je vous remercie
et je me tiens évidemment à votre
disposition pour répondre
merci Madame la Ministre évidemment le
débat est énorme vaste et merci d'avoir
ajouté quelques éléments de réflexion
d'actualité
je ne tournais vers les rapporteurs
messieurs
qui veut commencer allez Gilbert Luc il
souhaite que je prenne la parole en
premier
merci de votre éclairage madame la
ministre
comme on n'est pas tout à fait la même
génération je ne suis pas de la
générations de la méthode Coué voilà je
suis plutôt été éduqué à regarder les
choses plus négativement que
positivement
ce qui peut conduire à une
incompréhension à un moment mais je me
méfie beaucoup de la méthode Coué par
mon expérience de Luc local ça peut
conduire rapidement dans le mur parce
qu'on est très satisfait de ce que l'on
a fait et dans la réalité c'est pas
perçu du tout comme ça si je prends le
guichet unique par exemple je suis
désolé mais
sans vouloir redébattre ici j'ai posé
une question j'ai eu une réponse pas
très satisfaisante mais le guichet
unique même en ayant été fait à
expliquer
les choses par l'INPI où on peut
comprendre toute la problématique on
peut pas considérer que la façon dont on
s'y pris pour monter le guichet unique
on a considéré les chambres consulaires
comme des partenaires on les a
considérés comme des comme des acteurs
et je ne suis pas sûr qu'elles étaient
associées comme il le fallait pour la
réussite de ce guichet unique et puis on
peut on peut noter d'autres choses c'est
que il suffit pas de mettre sous forme
informatique formulaire
parce que le formulaire quand vous avez
quelqu'un en face de vous ce qui était
le cas dans la chambre de l'artisanat
des métiers
l'employé qui aidait à remplir le
formulaire répondait toute une série
d'interrogations le chef de chef
d'entreprise celui qui va monter son
entreprise par exemple qui se retrouve
face à un écran avec le même formulaire
qui a été mis sous écran il a personne
pour l'aider à répondre mais bon ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que ça on peut
considérer que ça peut être une réussite
on a noté tous les efforts que font les
ingénieurs d'une pi pour y remédier mais
je crois que culturellement il y a un
problème c'est qu'il faut que ce type
d'organisme considère
ce pour qui sont en train d'over non pas
comme des pions ou des acteurs mais
comme des partenaires et les associés
parce que ce produit enfin cette
démarche est le va évoluer elle va avoir
des modifications et ces modifications
si on veut qu'elle soit réussie il faut
associer
ce pour qui elles vont bénéficier
et le faire dans le temps et j'ai pas
noté cette volonté d'aller par là et
donc j'avais une série de questions
alors je suis aussi comme vous la norme
c'est pas forcément mauvais si je prends
les péfaces qui polluent le rôle en ce
moment on peut regretter qu'il y a pas
dedans voilà donc il faut pas non plus
systématiquement dire que toute norme
est mauvaise par contre ce que j'ai noté
en participant à cette mission c'est
qu'à un moment donné il y a un cumul de
norme qui arrive sur une entreprise et
c'est ce queule de normes qui peut être
difficilement gérable d'autant plus
quand l'entreprise elle est une TPE ou
une PME une plus grosse entreprise peut
les moyens disposer ou de d'embaucher
les gens pour pouvoir y répondre la
première question c'est quels sont selon
vous les obstacles parce que pas la
première fois qu'on se penche sur la
simplification des normes je crois que
un rapport de 1990 il y en a eu avant
bon et quels sont les obstacles selon
vous
au contrôle par une autorité
indépendante de la qualité des études
d'impact pourquoi ne pas recourir à des
tests auprès des PME avant de lancer une
norme ou une politique publique
concernant toutes les entreprises
il me semble aussi qu'on pourrait se
poser la question comment on développe
une culture de l'accompagnement des
entreprises au sein d'administration
et et
comment l'administration comprend aussi
mieux la culture des entreprises et
comment renforcer l'évaluation
l'efficacité des lois votées par le
Parlement dans le domaine économique
voilà moi je suis intéressé par vous
entendre sur sur ces questions là on a
vu alors c'est plutôt l'Europe du Nord
mais en Hollande il y a des choses qui
sont intéressantes qui ont été mis en
place la manière réfléchie vous avez
parlé de l'Europe en Hollande ils sont
prêts aussi à regarder évaluer ce qui
leur vient de l'Europe dans la façon
dont ils sont organisés et ça nous a
semblé à me semble-t-il des démarches
intéressantes dans lesquelles pour
lesquelles on devrait essayer de s'en
inspirer
merci Gilbert je vous propose peut-être
de prendre
une après les autres les questions donc
j'ajouterais quand même à la remarque de
Gilbert Luc de vinasse sur le cumul des
des normes pour eux-mêmes entreprises la
difficulté supplémentaire qui a quand en
plus de la cumul il y a
des normes qui sont opposées dans leurs
exigences et là on rencontre des chefs
d'entreprise qui sont devant des
échéances
d'applications avec l'incapacité
matérielle de résoudre
le paradoxe de de norme qui sont
antagonistes on l'a vu dans des très
grandes entreprises en particulier dans
le domaine de l'emballage et le souvenir
d'une visite dans le Jura nous on a vu
des gens qui une entreprise de 600
salariés disons à telle date je sais pas
si je pourrais continuer à travailler
j'ai une liste de normes je m'adresse à
tel ministère
on dit une chose c'est l'autre me dit
une autre il y a ce problème aussi de
voilà que vous avez que vous connaissez
par cœur mais qu'il faut qu'il faut
avoir en tête il y a pas que le cumul il
y a dans le cumul le fait que certaines
normes sont antagonistes je vous laisse
la parole
merci monsieur le Président gabarit
monsieur le sénateur de vinasse déjà
vous dire avec amitié que je ne suis pas
une partisane ni de l'auto-satisfaction
ni de la méthode Coué et ça va démarrer
puisque
il faut démontrer les choses plutôt que
les déclarer sur le guichet unique
je n'ai jamais nié les difficultés
j'ai pas ce matin que je vais commencer
comme on est
filmé je fais aussi évidemment attention
à ce que je dis
mais je vais assumer un propos devant
vous
parce que j'aime bien être très sincère
quand je m'exprime dans la vie en
général
une des difficultés en réalité sur le
guichet unique
et je suis bien placé pour le savoir
c'est que ça a été voté dans une loi qui
s'appelle la loi impact que je connais
bien article 1 et 2 je les connais bien
j'ai contribué à les écrire
en réalité cette loi elle a été
promulguée en mai 2019
en réalité cette loi pour une fois
elle a des défauts mais pour une fois
l'intégralité des décrets d'applications
a été publiés dans l'année suivant la
promulgation en mai 19 ce qui veut dire
que au printemps 2020
cette loi était efficiente
en 2020
portant cette loi j'ai terminé de la
porter et puis je monte au sein du
gouvernement au service de l'économie
sociale et solidaire qu'est-ce que je
remarque
je remarque une des choses les plus
délétères qui est dans notre
organisation
c'est qu'il y a parfois des évolutions
qui font que sur un sujet qui a été voté
celui ou celle qui était en charge
a évolué et donc pendant un an et demi
pendant 18 mois 24 mois
et je le dis devant vous sénateurs de
vinases j'estime que nous n'avons pas
porté assez d'attention à l'exécution
et à la mise en œuvre du guichet unique
ce sont des sujets vous le savez vous
l'avez dit sénateur qui qui sont très
massifs
en ligne faire converger des opérateurs
publics ou culture différentes la masse
de données
l'intéropérabilité du système
d'information enfin c'est pas un petit
projet et ces projets c'est comme du
lait sur le feu
et donc il y a eu je pense une
déficience d'attention et de suivi
pendant 12 18 mois
qui font que moi je me suis
retrouvé au côté de Bruno Le Maire à
l'été 22
et que nous étions en plein dans le pré
déploiement j'insiste parce que il y a
quand même eu des tests PME il y a eu
tout un prêt déploiement en 2022 toute
une partie des formalités qui ont été
basculer
et en l'occurrence j'ai maintenant le
plaisir de répondre
soit des questions d'actualité soit des
questions d'audition
fort de l'insatisfaction légitime que
vous avez et je les prends mais
véritablement je pense que si on se dit
les choses là où il y a eu
défaillances c'est dans le suivi de la
mise en oeuvre et de l'exécution de
cette loi pacte en 2020 sur ce sujet
précis du guichet unique
quand je récupère le dossier
il est pas forcément
très bien enclenché je vous rappelle pas
l'objectif du guichet unique vous le
savez mieux que moi et il y a des
dysfonctionnements
donc moi qu'est-ce que je fais je prends
les critiques c'est normal sinon faut
faire autre chose et puis deuxièmement
j'essaie de pallier ces
dysfonctionnements le plus vite possible
avec le soutien du ministre de
l'économie
on a et vous le savez même si c'est pas
une audition guichet unique mais
on a partiellement ouvert un faux grève
vous le savez le temps que le guichet
soit pleinement opérationnel la voie
papier a été autorisée en complément de
la voix dématérialisée l'assistance
téléphonique aux côtés des entrepreneurs
des indépendants des artisans
répond à un couteau de couverture d'un
peu plus de 95% et a toujours une
sollicitation forte qui démontre la
nécessité d'un accompagnement humain si
mille appel par jour en moyenne
un audit technique très récent a permis
à limpide améliorer l'efficience de
l'architecture d'ensemble du projet
les mandataires sont associés à des
séances de recettage technique
hebdomadaires pour identifier et
permettre de corriger les bugs
techniques
une décision va être prise très très
prochainement par le gouvernement quant
au maintien éventuel des solutions dites
de secours Infogreffe et guichet
entreprise principalement pour les
modalités de modificatif les formalités
pardon de modification
le temps de stabiliser le fonctionnement
du guichet
début juin je partage juste ces chiffres
avec vous c'est un peu plus de 600 000
créations
25000 cessations
70% d'entre elles sont finalisées et
inscrites au rne
36000 dépôts de compte
sujet sur lequel j'ai apporté une
attention certaine depuis des mois en
lien avec la présidente des
experts-comptables soyons clairs depuis
des mois sur le dépôt des cons le taux
de validation par les grèves dépassent
les 80% aujourd'hui
et les formalités de cession sont
ouverts depuis le 1er mai on en compte
un peu plus de 700 par jour pour
terminer sur le dépôt des comptes
réalisables depuis le 1er mai en ligne
nous en comptons auprès de 1000 par jour
et les formalités de modification sont
ouvertes depuis fin mai pour les
personnes physiques ce sera le cas en
juin pour les personnes morales
donc je ne reviens pas sur
votre question légitime je vous ai dit
ce que j'en pensais après moi l'objectif
c'est de faire en sorte que ça
fonctionne quand même et que ça avance
loin de l'auto-satisfaction après ce qui
me frappe aussi et je vous le dis
c'est que je suis possiblement la seule
à Bercy enfin même plus que possible qui
un jour s'est retrouvé
en formalité de création
faut Eugène Saccomano le disait bien
faut pas non plus qu'on refasse le match
moi en indépendance j'ai vécu un enfer à
la création je savais pas où aller je
savais pas qu'elle CFE choisir je savais
pas qu'elle statut choisir je suis allé
à la CCI on m'a dit on traite pas les
indépendants je suis allé à la CMA on
m'a dit on traite pas les indépendants
donc j'ai pas dit que vous refaisiez le
match sénateur mais
c'était quand même pas idéal j'en dans
ça fonctionnait et c'était quand même
pas idéal et sacrément compliqué pour un
certain nombre de gens
c'est un projet massif qui a eu sur
certainement un suivi un peu lacunaire
je l'accorde sans emballage devant vous
ce qui m'importe c'est que je pense que
dans les mois qui viennent on va réussir
à avoir enfin un guichet création
modification Sécession qui sera quand
même malgré les difficultés
plus facile pour les créateurs
d'entreprise ou les entrepreneurs qui
souhaitent modifier ou CD mais on
partait quand même de d'une réalité qui
était assez complexe et qu'il faudrait
pas
repeindre comme étant parfaite parce
qu'elle ne l'était pas donc on continue
le boulot je comprends aisément les
critiques reprochées notamment par les
sénateurs et je vous garantis que je
fais tout ce que je peux avec Bruno Le
Maire pour qu'on soit à la hauteur
de l'engagement sur le guichet unique
sur test PME
moi je suis évidemment
[Musique]
acquise alors après
test PME en réalité on a un sujet au
plan européen
aujourd'hui je l'ai dit à Bruxelles je
pense qu'on n'est ni assez systématique
ni assez
il y a pas assez d'ampleur pour les
tests PME qui sont réalisés
dans le cadre de la législation
européenne
après modestement je vous dirais que il
n'est pas un texte et vous me direz
heureusement mais il n'est pas un texte
c'est pas un décret il y a pas une
négociation même je le vois dans
l'agroalimentaire depuis des mois ou moi
je porte pas le test PME faire que je
sur chacun des textes réglementaires ou
normatifs
soit les PME sont exclus je prends
l'exemple des renégociations
commerciales ou de du pack de solidarité
commerciale qui a été mise en œuvre avec
les distributeurs en fin d'année ou les
PME ont été exclus
soit les PME sont concernés mais avec
une temporalité une progressivité une
proportionnalité
à laquelle je veille chaque jour
vous aviez
aussi alors sur les consulats juste sur
les consulaires je le redis et comme
j'ai aussi l'honneur de travailler avec
eux depuis le début les consulaires a
commencé par les CMA siège au comité de
pilotage qui a été mise en place par
Bruno Le Maire à l'époque
depuis le début
malgré les réticences et d'ailleurs je
salue les CMA puisqu'on le retire une
compétence ils ont siégé au sein du
comité de pilotage depuis le début du
projet sur le guichet unique
sur l'accompagnement administratif
je vais aller assez vite parce que le
temps passe
j'ai quelques exemples quand même à
partager avec vous
d'abord je porte et j'en ai pas encore
parlé parce que d'abord on fait et
ensuite on parle enfin moi j'aime bien
faire les choses comme ça je porte
depuis des mois un programme dont
j'aurai le plaisir je pense de parler
cet été et peut-être de rendre compte
devant les sénateurs à la rentrée
programme qui s'appelle étincelle
ce programme voyez-vous il a un objectif
c'est d'embarquer des PME de croissance
vers pour devenir des ETI je n'ai rien
inventé
mais on a une vraie politique au service
des industries et des ETI on a une vraie
politique à l'endroit de la French tech
et des sociétés technologiques il me
semblerait de bonnes à loi de ne pas
oublier celle qui forme 95% de nos
entreprises c'est à dire des PME dont
les PME de croissance sur ce programme
étincelle pour vous répondre sur
l'accompagnement des entreprises c'est
un programme qui n'est que
d'accompagnement des entreprises
le constat est assez simple et il est
partagé par les entrepreneurs que j'ai
sollicité
il y a 15 20 ans on avait énormément de
problèmes de financement il en demeure
un certain nombre mais une partie des
problèmes de financement se sont
améliorés notamment par le truchement de
la BPI
on a aujourd'hui un vrai enjeu qui est
l'accompagnement
il y a du financement je le vois
beaucoup par exemple dans les aides à la
transition écologique qui sont au nombre
je vous confie ce chiffre de pas moins
de 140 aides à la transition écologique
pour les entreprises
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que
l'entrepreneur c'est pas qu'il manque
d'aide c'est que il faut trouver l'aide
il faut être capable de la déclenché il
faut se faire accompagner pour l'obtenir
on a aussi un certain nombre de PME de
croissance dont l'État lui-même
grève le développement
par des normes par des problématiques de
fiscalité par des embus à l'export par
des problèmes de visa j'en vois tous les
jours et donc sans en faire état dans
les médias parce que c'est pas l'objet
c'est un programme j'irai un peu
technique j'ai mis en place au sein de
l'administration
des correspondants est un sel dans
quasiment une soixantaine
d'administrations qui vont de la BPI à
luga qui vend du ministère de la
transition écologique au ministère de
l'alimentation évidemment sans oublier
merci
pour que les PME de croissance puisse
avoir des correspondants au sein même de
l'État pour les aider à déblayer
d'énormes des embûches qui les empêchent
de croître
ça c'est un programme que j'annoncerai
il fallait déjà le mettre en œuvre et le
construire que j'annoncerai dans les
prochains prochaines semaines ou mois on
verra quand mais la mission de ce
programme est un sel n'est que de
l'accompagnement depuis l'intérieur de
l'État à l'endroit de CPME de croissance
façon aussi de témoigner du fait que
il y a un problème d'accompagnement et
donc il faut y pallier et au même titre
qu'on a d'autres correspondants dans
tous les ministères pour certains sujets
il est indispensable que nous ayons nous
en ayons pour les PME pour être capable
de déblayer un certain nombre de
problèmes réglementaires ou normatifs
j'ajoute que au-delà de mon action la D
i TP que vous connaissez bien un pilote
en ce moment même France expérimentation
qui permet la mise en œuvre beaucoup
plus facile de dérogation à titre
temporaire expérimental
pour donner lieu à des modifications
législatives ultérieures
et je voudrais quand même pas oublier
parce que pour le coup je pense que
c'est là que la compagnement est le plus
efficient et j'en remercie aussi les
consulaires sur lesquels on s'appuie
beaucoup mais je voudrais pas qu'on
oublie
les acteurs publics parmi lesquels les
sous préfets
référents à France 2030 les sous-prés à
la relance qui ont accompagné
incroyablement nos entreprises pour
aller chercher des financements liés au
plan de relance
j'aurais pas qu'on oublie les
conseillers départementaux à la sortie
de crise avec lesquels je suis en
contact quasiment quotidiennement pour
accompagner à la main des dizaines de
milliers d'entreprises notamment dans le
crises dans le cas de la crise
énergétique que nous avons vécue vous
parliez des CMA les CMA ont je le disais
au Parlement mardi ont appelé des
dizaines de milliers de boulanger par
exemple
en présence des conseillers
départementaux à la sortie de crise pour
apporter à chacun de ces artisans des
réponses et des solutions donc il y a eu
un accompagnement au niveau local qui se
poursuit vraiment à hauteur de TPME pas
un accompagnement national à hauteur de
TPME
et il ne faudrait pas oublier non plus
les CRP comme ici en restructuration à
la prévention de difficultés des
entreprises qui interviennent aussi sur
des entreprises de taille un peu
supérieur mais qui ont été extrêmement
mobilisés durant la crise énergétique
je termine en vous disant que nous avons
annoncé récemment le déploiement d'un
service d'accompagnement spécifique pour
les PME sur les sujets fiscaux qui va
être déployée dans 36 directions
départementales autour d'un
interlocuteur fiscal des PME
spécifiquement
l'objectif ça va être de renforcer
l'accompagnement des entreprises dans
les territoires et de continuer à
accompagner plus nos PME
donc la culture de l'accompagnement au
même titre que la confiance je crois
qu'elle ne se décrète pas elle se
pratique on a encore une fois
certainement des progrès à accomplir au
niveau national j'essaye modestement dit
contribuer avec le programme étincelle
qui est un programme déficience plus que
de communication
mais je veux aussi saluer et vous dire
le plus simplement du monde que sans
l'aide des services des concentrés et de
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques que
je viens de vous citer
nous n'aurions pas pu accompagner et
continuer d'accompagner nos TPME dans
les difficultés à la fois
inflationnistes côté intrant mais aussi
énergique énergétique pardonnez-moi
ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas des
progrès à faire
alors on va demander à Olivier Rickman
de prendre la suite si vous avez
organisé votre passage comme ça
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vais raccourcir un petit peu
je suis longue ah non non c'est pas
votre c'est pas votre égard que je dis
ça
ah mais je vais le faire je vais le
faire quand même je voulais faire une
toute petite réflexion je suis pas du
style à armée le couteau dans la plaine
mais juste une toute petite réflexion
sur l'INPI on a on a eu l'opportunité
d'auditionner ici la délégation aux
entreprises Stanislas new château
président fondateur de doctolib 20
millions de connexions par mois une
remise à jour trois fois par jour à tous
les bugs réglés en moins de 5 minutes ça
fait quelques mois qu'on parle de Limpy
avec la l'état de la puissance publique
de l'État c'est pas normal voilà c'est
tout ce que je voulais dire il y a quand
même des questions à se poser non moi
madame la ministre je voulais vous
parler d'étude d'impact vous en avez
parlé un petit peu à travers des
exemples concrets trop souvent il est
proposé au Parlement des dispositions
qui ont un coût pour les entreprises
certains indirects sans qu'il soit
estimés sérieusement voire pas du tout
je prendrai justement deux exemples
concrets récents le premier est celui de
l'index seniors dans le projet de la loi
de financement rectificatif la sécurité
sociale disposition censurée car
considéré comme cavalier social par le
Conseil constitutionnel mais si je
prends l'étude d'impact de l'article 2
elle était tout simplement muette sur le
coup de la mise en œuvre pour chaque
entreprise dans son élaboration je cite
si je prends le petit a impact sur les
assurés et les redevable notamment en
termes de démarche de formalité ou de
charge administrative réponse sans objet
l'étude d'impact était également
elliptique sur son impact économique
cantonné à des dimensions
macroéconomiques tenant en une seule
ligne
impact économique la mesure a pour
objectif d'améliorer l'insertion et le
maintien des seniors dans l'emploi et
ainsi diminuer le taux de chômage et
augmenter l'activité parmi les
travailleurs seniors en termes d'études
d'impact peut mieux faire pourquoi le
guide méthodologique pour calculer
l'impact économique et financier de la
norme de neurones 2019 élaboré par le
Secrétariat général du gouvernement
n'a-t-il pas été utilisé
il comporte pourtant un page 8 un
tableau de calcul de la durée des tâches
correspondant à la construction d'une
obligation d'information telle que c'est
index senior
ce tableau permet de calculer une durée
théorique de l'attache administrative
qui peut être considéré par
administration comme facile modérée ou
complexe cette durée théorique est-elle
corroborée par une confrontation avec la
réalité en interrogeant des entreprises
la réponse est jamais
pourquoi l'administration de
demande-t-elle pas aux entreprises leur
vécu en chiffrant le coup réel
mon deuxième exemple madame la ministre
est tiré du projet de loi pour contrôler
l'immigration améliorer l'intégration
dont le Parlement sera sans doute saisi
un jour et dans son article 2 qui met à
la charge de l'employeur une obligation
de formation à la langue française
quel sera le coût final de cette
obligation pour l'entreprise quel sera
le coût de l'impact sur son organisation
lorsque le salarié sera en formation et
qu'il faudra le remplacer à son poste de
travail là encore l'étude d'impact
dramatiquement muette et se contente de
considération générale je prends la
phrase qui m'a le plus impacté c'est le
cas de le dire dans l'étude d'impact les
formations linguistiques qui seront
proposées par les employeurs dans le
cadre du plan de développement des
compétences pourront faire l'objet de
prise en charge financière prévu ainsi
le coût de la formation pour être pris
en charge par l'entreprise directement
fermer le banc la conclusion madame la
ministre c'est que l'étude d'impact n'a
même plus pour fonction de justifier le
recours à la norme ni même de chiffrer
son coude pour l'entreprise elle ne sert
à rien car sa pertinence n'est contrôlée
par personne
le problème est structurel il fait de la
France un cas isolé je reprends votre
expression madame la ministre quand je
me vois je me fais peur quand je me
compare je me rassure sur le sujet quand
je me vois je me fais peur quand je me
compare je fais les cauchemars on a eu
l'occasion dans cette mission
d'auditionner et de se déplacer Pays-Bas
la Commission européenne qui a mis en
place une structure d'évaluation et des
impacts les Suisses les Allemands on est
encore à Londres vendredi dernier tous
tous ont mis en place depuis certains
dix ans des systèmes d'études d'impact
en relation directe avec les entreprises
avec des conséquences sur des économies
financières je pense à la Hollande 2,5
milliards d'économies sur les
entreprises l'Allemagne 12 milliards la
Suisse on est entre 1 et 1 milliard et
demi par an d'économie sur les
entreprises tous appelés à ce que la
France notamment les pays de la
Communauté européenne appel à ce que la
France met en place un tel dispositif
alors que la France ne le fait pas déjà
parce qu'il considère que la France
serait d'un poids capital à côté de
au niveau de la Commission européenne
mais aussi parce que la France attirait
également des pays comme l'Italie ou
l'Espagne
partout en Europe l'étude d'impact est
sérieuse chiffrée et validé par une
institution indépendante où est le
blocage qui s'oppose à ce que les études
d'impact chiffre
les coûts de la norme pour nos
entreprises merci madame la ministre
ment
de répondre à l'impact
ce qu'une bouée qui me faudrait la
sénateur je
non mais
il y a deux options scarwell disait je
veux pas je suis moi-même les autres
sont déjà pris
j'ai fait trois ans et demi de Parlement
j'ai en tête en vous écoutant cette
amendement
que j'ai porté qui devait être un des
premiers que j'ai porté sur les actions
gratuites qui est un sujet qui me
passionne pour abaisser la fiscalité
on devait être même pas fin 2017
et je me souviens de ce moment immense
de ceitude ou l'opposition me questionne
sur le coup de la mesure
et à l'époque j'étais député et déjà je
m'étais dit souvenez-vous nous étions
quelques-uns autour d'Amélie de mon
Chalin Jean-Noël Barrault Laurence
Martin
je me dis c'est pas possible que moi je
fasse mon travail de parlementaire dans
une telle obscurité parce que c'est
grave de pas savoir si un amendement
coûte 3 millions 30 millions ou 300
millions
donc j'ai pas changé en 2023 et je vais
pas refaire le match et vous dire non
non il y a pas de problème c'est pas ma
nature c'est pas
je pense qu'il y a plusieurs problèmes
et vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs c'est un
problème c'est un enjeu structurel je
vais essayer d'ouvrir quelques pistes
je pense déjà que c'est un problème du
côté
de l'action au gouvernementale mais je
pense aussi que c'est un sujet du côté
des parlementaires de doter les
parlementaires et c'est d'ailleurs ce
que nous avions essayé de faire avec
Jean-Noël Barrault et à l'époque et mes
autres collègues parlementaires à la
commission des finances à l'Assemblée de
pouvoir essayer d'avoir
une autorité un lieu un budget pour
pouvoir mieux étayer et comment il
s'appelle ce logiciel que Jean-Noël a
déployé le logiciel à la comme fille qui
permet d'évaluer les amendements c'est
pas grave je m'en souviens moi donc on a
mis en place un logiciel qui permet aux
député de travailler un peu mieux le
l'impact budgétaire de
leur proposition c'était largement
nécessaire c'est pas suffisant on a à
défaut d'avoir parfois des études
d'impact ou des éléments étayés en amont
on avait promu ce qui existe toujours ce
printemps de l'évaluation qui permet
aussi d'évaluer alors vous me direz expo
et je vous l'accorde des mesures mais
qui parfois ont des coûts budgétaires
bien plus importants que ce qu'on avait
envisagé je ne peux qu'encourager à
maintenir et surtout à continuer à
donner du sens au printemps de
l'évaluation
parce que je pense que c'est un moment
important de
la relation entre les le Parlement et
l'exécutif et que nous devons rendre
compte de l'action et qu'il est très
important qu'on est cette pression aussi
de
rendre compte au parlementaire à l'aune
du printemps de l'évaluation
aujourd'hui vous l'avez mentionné donc
je vais pas revenir dessus le guide qui
a été mis en place bon il a le mérite
d'exister mais la réalité c'est que
comme il y a pas d'obligation
d'utilisation de référence obligé etc
c'est un peu en fonction des bonnes
volontés donc ça n'est pas assez
c'est pas assez solide et voilà l'ex
impact merci l'ex-impact à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pas satisfaisant
la réalité c'est que pour mesurer le
coût d'une contrainte nouvelle et c'est
un sujet passionnant il y a deux
méthodes distinctes qui sont utilisées
vous le savez la méthode des coûts réels
la méthode des coûts standards
aujourd'hui
je pense et c'était intéressant de vous
entendre sur la Hollande et l'Europe du
Nord je pense qu'il serait intéressant
de regarder d'autres méthodes qui
marchent peut-être mieux dans d'autres
pays
moi je vous le dis ça m'intéresse
peut-être d'échanger pierre si tu as le
temps après sur la Hollande je connais
pas la situation en revanche on regarde
de près nous ce qui se fait en Allemagne
avec le Conseil national enfin le NKR du
contrôle des normes depuis 15 ans
qui assure un caractère compréhensif de
la nouvelle réglementation et puis qui
identifie les coûts à chaque nouvelle
réglementation
nous on a grâce à vous une instance
consultative vous le savez la CCEN qui
est devenu le Conseil national de
l'évaluation des normes en 2013 qui est
chargé de manière obligatoire de se
prononcer sur les textes ayant un impact
sur les collectivités territoriales
on pourrait élargir le périmètre aussi
du Conseil national d'évaluation des
normes au-delà du territoire idéal
l'instant allemande qu'on regarde elle a
défini une méthodologie très précise
fondée d'ailleurs sur les coûts directs
dont je vous parlais l'investissement en
temps que vous mentionniez page 8 du
guide méthodologique si une industrie
par exemple doit acheter des filtres à
particules ou si un type d'éleveur
agricole doit engager des coups pour la
santé des pour les animaux à ce
moment-là les coûts sont estimés
chiffrés et intégrés à contrario les
coups de fiscalité par exemple ne sont
pas estimés ni l'analyse des bénéfices
des entreprises
en France la compétence d'estimation des
coûts techniques et financiers revient
au Conseil national d'évaluation des
normes
si la délégation aux entreprises
pardonnez-moi dans le cas d'une étude
approfondie de la méthodo mise en place
par le NKR allemand formule des
suggestions pour améliorer l'étude
d'impact pour les entreprises j'y serai
plus attentive
voilà je vais pas dites moi
juste une petite précision si vous
permettez madame la ministre le NKR
allemand c'est inspiré les Allemands se
sont rodés par inspirés du système des
Pays-Bas ils sont allés voir les
Pays-Bas et ils ont créé le NKR à partir
de ce que font les Pays-Bas
pardon excusez-moi
c'est cette histoire de Wanin Winehouse
[Musique]
alors nous comme on aime sur transposer
on a fait Wanin tout
et moi je vous propose
wanini out
moi je trouve ça intéressant mais je
trouve ça dommage en terme de périmètre
voilà dans le cadre de vos suggestions
on en reparle quand vous voulez mais
dans le cas des échanges que j'avais
hier sur waninia août avec nos collègues
européens
l'idée d'un élargissement au-delà du
pouvoir réglementaire
pour être intéressant
on poursuit les questions Jean-Pierre
mega réfléchir
donc je vais essayer de compléter mes
collègues je mets le micro devant moi
abordé pas mal de sujets celui notamment
des études d'impact ou effectivement
l'occasion
d'aller voir à l'étranger ceux qui se
faisait et chez nous moi ce qu'on
constate au cours des auditions que l'on
a fait on voit que les fonctionnaires
les représentants des ministères etc
connaissent très bien le problème
et c'est vrai ils ont même lu avec
beaucoup d'attention tous les rapports
qui ont été faits mais par contre au
niveau des solutions je dirais on attend
on attend toujours
j'ai
entendu dire dans d'autres métiers on
connaît bien la maladie mais pour les
remèdes on va on est en train d'attendre
moi je voudrais aborder de deux autres
choses d'abord le constat c'est que en
France quand même quand on veut
construire une entreprise on met deux
fois plus de temps qu'ailleurs ou trois
fois plus donc on a un problème à ce à
ce niveau là et on parlait tout à
l'heure du rapport avec l'administration
moi je crois que et madame la ministre
c'est là-dessus que je voudrais vous
vous interroger je crois qu'il faut
améliorer les rapports entre les
entreprises les porteurs de projets les
et puis l'administration parce que il y
a
de l'application de certaines normes il
y a des pays où on travaille
je dirais c'est un terme industriel 20
ans masqué c'est-à-dire qu'on fait
plusieurs choses en même temps nous en
France quand on veut construire une
usine par exemple il y a une
installation classique tant que on n'a
pas résolu le problème de l'installation
de l'installation classée pardon on peut
pas déposer le permis de construire donc
on va perdre une installation classée il
faut au moins un an on va perdre non
alors que parallèlement à ça on pourrait
peut-être faire un certain nombre de
choses et est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
qu'à ce niveau là il y a il y a un
travail à faire au niveau de
l'administration pour améliorer ces
choses et arriver à faire ce qui se fait
dans d'autres pays c'est-à-dire que
mettre dans ou un angle de 1000
enfin oui là où aujourd'hui on met trois
avant donc je sais qu'il y a il y a du
travail qui est fait là-dessus mais je
pense que il faudrait continuer et après
l'énorme il faut aussi combat les devant
nos portes parce que ce soit l'Assemblée
ou chez nous quand on fait aussi 2000
amendements ou 3000 amendement pour
modifier une là je suis pas sûr que les
parlementaires ont eu aussi dans le sens
de la de la simplification et là aussi
il faut peut-être que nous travaillons
ensemble et dans nos règlements pour
essayer de faire des consolidations pour
certaines choses regardez peut-être les
conséquences alors on est souvent en
procédure accélérée aussi
mais ça mériterait peut-être quelquefois
que l'on prenne le le temps
ensemble de de regarder l'impact on
parlait tout à l'heure
des études d'impact de
de ce que l'on fait moi je
vais pas rajouter
grand chose mais je crois que je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez mais la
culture de l'accompagnement des
entreprises
dites-nous ce que vous en pensez si vous
ne pensez pas qu'il faut l'améliorer
améliorer la
pédagogie et puis peut-être expliquer
l'intérêt parce que les normes peuvent
avoir et ont de l'intérêt il y a les
normes notamment ISO les entreprises
elles sont très contraignantes pour les
entreprises mais il émettent en place
parce qu'il y a un intérêt on pourrait
peut-être essayer d'expliquer
que ma foi certains textes certaines
normes sont faits aussi pour des raisons
précises et que les entreprises
en tout cas ceux qui doivent les mettre
en place
doivent le faire parce que il y a un
intérêt voilà je vous remercie
en fait je trouve qu'il y a quelque
chose et je me permets de le dire
chapeau créateur Moga
qui est assez difficile pour pas dire un
gras
mais qui se vérifie toujours sur
l'accompagnement aux entreprises et
d'ailleurs qui se confirment sur
l'accompagnement au ménage
on ne remonte que ce qui va pas
le nombre de TPE de PME qui sont
accompagnés à la main une à une par des
sous-prés
par des conseillers départementaux à la
sortie de crise par les CRP par les
dreads vous savez moi le vendredi c'est
le train l'avion c'est pas Paris tous
les vendredis donc ça fait
55 60 déplacements sur l'année qui vient
de se passer je les vois c'est pas des
adresses mail pour moi c'est Jean qui
accompagnent les entreprises je les vois
je peux vous en citer j'en connais plein
sur le territoire pierre mon conseiller
qui est ici et tous les jours en contact
avec les services des concentrés en lien
et en organisation du lien entre
l'adminisation centrale les services des
concentrés et puis surtout les solutions
pour les entreprises au bout de la
chaîne
je veux juste avoir ce mot et
je ne nie aucunement le sujet de
confiance et je vais y revenir mais
beaucoup plus que les trains encore qui
n'arrivent pas à l'heure on remonte
toujours ce qui va pas et c'est encore
plus vrai sur les TPE les PME les
entreprises alors même qu'il y a quand
même des dizaines de milliers d'agents
qui font un boulot remarquable
mais au même titre que ne remonte dans
la PQR que les entreprises en très
grande difficulté je le sais puisque
chacune qui remonte nous les contactons
alors peut-être pas nous avec nos 06
mais les services déconcentrés on a mis
en place une procédure on a encore en
voyant on est jeudi mardi je lis un
papier dans la PQR une boulangère qui
fait des crises d'angoisse
on appelle on appelle tout de suite le
sous-préfet on appelle tout de suite le
Conseil départemental a sorti de crise
on fait le lien avec la des défis avec
l'adresse
et cette dame qui avait des crises
d'angoisse et j'ai monté moins à gauche
quand on l'a fait contacter mais déjà ne
serait-ce que d'aller vers elle
ça diminue une partie de l'angoisse
c'est pas elle d'appeler trouver le bon
numéro le bon mail le bon sous-préfet
préfet tout ça est très flou pour les
gens mais le fait que on l'appelle qu'on
la contacte pour l'aider ne serait-ce
que ça ça j'irais de dégonfler la
baudruche on lui a dit on va trouver des
solutions on va et donc je veux juste
avoir un mot pour tous ces gens qui tous
les jours dans les préfectures dans les
services des concentrés accompagnent des
PME des TPE et dont on ne parle jamais
et au même titre d'ailleurs que parfois
dans la justice on parle toujours comme
ça va pas on parle jamais quand il y a
un équipement un non-lieu voir une
solution qui a été trouvée donc je pense
qu'on s'améliore en vrai et je pense
sincèrement que la solution
du traitement elle est à hauteur
d'entreprise elle n'est pas à hauteur du
139 rue de Bercy
si on veut être efficace si on veut voir
le chef d'entreprise qui va pas bien
parce qu'il ouvre plus sa boîte aux
lettres parce qu'il a pas payé son urssa
parce qu'il a pas payé la CIPAV parce
qu'il est en retard sur CNAO vous savez
ce moment vous l'avez été on n'ouvre
plus la boîte aux lettres
c'est pas la ministre qui doit l'appeler
ça lui fera plaisir mais ça résoudra pas
son problème c'est un plaisir ça dépend
c'est à hauteur de territoire et moi de
plus en plus je pense que
l'accompagnement il faut qu'on
délègue avec les soutiens financiers qui
vont avec mais le plus possible à
hauteur de TPE
parce que les dispositifs nationaux sont
beaucoup moins efficients
il y a quand même des choses
où on est un peu un décretable je le je
le concède monsieur le sénateur je vous
donne un exemple il est vraiment bête
un pot.gouv.fr
en tant que particulier ou en tant
qu'entreprise vous y déclaré
vos revenus et vous y établissez
vos comptes fiscaux
le simple fait de mettre les aides à
l'énergie
et j'y éveillé parce qu'il fallait bien
trouver une solution sur la page
d'accueil du site des impôts
ce simple geste
alors bien sûr il faut aller vite il
faut aller sur un site que tout le monde
connaît mais je vais vous le dire avec
humour en jeudi matin avez-vous déjà
croisé un entrepreneur qui va sur le
site des impôts pour se faire aider
mais parce qu'il y a un frein c'est pas
un réflexe c'est même et ça n'a rien à
voir avec la qualité des travaux
réalisés par nos agents mais c'est une
question de culture c'est une question
de et ça on va ça va nous prendre deux
siècles pour qu'un entrepreneur est plus
peur d'aller sur ces sites là et plus je
suis intimement persuadé qu'on a un
certain entrepreneurs qui n'y sont pas
allés pour demander l'aide parce que
c'était là
quand je dis ça des fois on prend pour
une hurle uberlue on aurait dit mon père
mais ça se joue à ça
un entrepreneur à part en réflexe
d'appeler l'URSSAF pour se faire aider
et c'est une erreur parce que l'URSSAF
l'aide bien souvent on étale on décale
mais cette culture et c'est pour ça que
je trouve ça bien qui est
une ancienne entrepreneur à Bercy
parfois
parce que la psychologie ça se lit pas
pour le coup dans les études d'impact et
puis moi j'ai pas c'est pas une question
de personne c'est une question de
réflexe culturel un entrepreneur n'est
jamais tranquille
si tandis qu'il soit petit quand il
appelle les impôts quand il appelle sa
banque
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec la qualité
de nos banquiers de nos agents des
impôts c'est une question de de d'état
d'esprit et ça ça prend du temps les
états d'esprit beaucoup plus que les
formulaires mais ça se joue à des petits
détails comme ça
voyons on aurait on ferait
je fais attention au sénateur de vidage
parce que il faut pas que ça devienne le
guichet unique non plus mais on pourrait
aussi faire un site Aide point
entreprise avec tout ce qui suit
derrière parce que ça fait 8 km nos
mails mais et nos sites Web mais je
pense qu'un certain nombre
d'entrepreneurs iraient plus
ça relève du détail mais ça c'est un
truc que j'ai appris en politique il y a
beaucoup de choses dans le détail et
dans l'exécution et parfois pour des
raisons de simplicité tout le monde
connaît le site des impôts oui mais
est-ce une raison suffisante
et donc moi j'essaye d'avoir ce réflexe
quitte à me faire contre arbitrer mais
au moins soulever le sujet
après il y a quand même deux trois
choses qui fonctionnent
je voulais et je l'avais préparé en vide
l'audition revenir sur
la loi et ceux qui est une des premières
qui a été portée au précédent mandat
je ne sais pas si elle a été évaluée
d'ailleurs
parce que 18 + 5 ça fait 23
alors l'idée déclarée en frontispice
l'état un partenaire de confiance pour
les entreprises
très concrètement et vous en souvenez
avant un contrôle les entreprises
peuvent régulariser spontanément leur
situation fiscale en bénéficiant en une
réduction de 50% du taux d'intérêt de
retard pour les entreprises de bonne foi
réduction portée à 30% si la
régularisation est faite pendant le
contrôle et l'entreprise a aussi la
possibilité expose de solliciter des
délais de paiement en cas de difficultés
trésorerie pour payer les impositions
supplémentaires
les déclarations correctives spontanées
en 2022 ont augmenté de 65% par rapport
à 2019
et plus de 40% des contrôles en 2022 se
sont conclus par acceptation des
contribuables ce qui représente une
hausse de 70% par rapport à 2019 en
termes monétaire et je voulais partager
ce chiffre
en termes monétaire ça représente 1,17
milliards de droits et 34 milliards
d'euros d'intérêts de retard donc voilà
typiquement
une politique qui a été mise en oeuvre
en 2018 dont on parle pas tous les jours
où j'étais sur les plateaux mais qui
très concrètement pour plus d'un
milliard de droits et pour 34 milliards
d'euros d'intérêts de retard fournit des
effets pour plus d'une voiture 2
donc il y a quand même des choses qui
sont en train de changer
même si la route est longue et que c'est
en partie une route aussi
psychologique après je terminerai en
vous disant ça ce qui me frappe
et c'est soit la beauté du geste soit la
gratitude du geste c'est que il suffit
et j'en ai en tête vous pouvez avoir 150
entreprises qui ont le droit à l'erreur
qui ont étalé leur paiement qui ont eu
les aides énergies qui décale leur
URSSAF qui ont une relation de confiance
mais comme la politique c'est la vie il
suffit d'une boîte
pour que
tout tout ce qui a été fait au niveau
local ou autre Tang par un papier dans
la PQR pas parce qu'il y a eu un
deuxième contrôle parce que et ça moi
même j'ai un exemple en tête très
concret
ou je ne me résous pas je vais vous le
dire je ne me résous pas je veux
comprendre parce que moi quand je
comprends pas ça va pas notre prise qui
a demandé un crédit d'impôt à qui on a
dit oui qui a attendu 6 mois à part son
crédit d'impôt tellement qu'elle pouvait
plus payer c'est ça il a rien
et puis au final on lui a dit tu as plus
le droit au crédit d'impôt
je sais pas si j'ai le droit à l'erreur
la relation de confiance mais ça ça tue
en entrepreneur ça tue une chose
sais-tu l'envie que le bonhomme a de se
battre de gérer sa boîte et de continuer
et c'est ça qui auquel il faut qu'on
fasse attention c'est qu'il suffit
parfois d'un
industriel dans un bassin d'emploi
qui a été mal accompagné qui a subi trop
de contrôle ou qui a été injustement
récriminé pour que l'ensemble du job qui
a été fait depuis des mois ou voir des
années par les services déconcentrés
c'est cool
et donc je sais qu'on a encore beaucoup
beaucoup pas faire d'ailleurs je sais
pas où est la ma fille mais si il faut
que je vous dise un truc sur industrie
verte il faut que je vous annonce plutôt
une bonne nouvelle sur laquelle je
voudrais travailler avec vous
merci sur non c'est le One merci sur
réindustrialisation verte pour revenir à
vos à vos points très précis sur les
délais
procédure de délivrance administrative
des autorisations prennent entre
enfin normalement neuf mois voilà
c'est bien
dans la vraie vie c'est 17 on est dans
la vraie vie c'est 17 mois donc en fait
on nous explique que ça dure 9 mois mais
ça dure ça dure deux fois plus donc là
voilà le pire n'étant jamais certain on
va vous proposer de raccourcir les
processus
objectif qu'il n'y ait plus contre 6 et
9 mois pour obtenir la délivrance de son
autorisation
mise en place d'une procédure
exceptionnellement simplifiée pour les
projets d'intérêt général pour ces
projets les différentes procédures
peuvent rallonger délai d'obtention des
autorisations de 24 mois
il y aura donc une procédure spéciale si
les parlementaires
sont d'accord qui sera piloté par l'État
et mise en place pour des projets
identifiés par des décrets du Premier
ministre pour accélérer les
installations
sachez que vous me retrouverez et que
j'aurai l'immense plaisir de vous
retrouver si je peux être au bon à
l'article 11 de ce projet de loi et
industrialisation verte
il serait dommage d'avoir un texte enfin
véhicule pour améliorer accélérer les
procédures au bénéfice de l'implantation
d'industrie vertes et de ne pas en
profiter pour quelques-unes
quelques-unes les autres j'en ai
modestement rajouté une au service des
zones commerciales pour accélérer et
simplifier
les procédures que vous connaissez
sûrement mais que j'avoue avoir
découvertes il y a un an qui porte le
doux nom de goût
ces grandes opérations d'urbanisme ou
pour des raisons procédurales le maire
doit confier le permis de construire au
président de PCI ce qui crée des
problèmes que vous connaissez ou des
tensions que vous connaissez comme moi
et ce qui met à mal dépend entier de
rénovation deux zones ou de friches
commerciales donc de façon très
opérationnelle j'aurai des propositions
au sein de cet article 11 là aussi pour
au-delà de l'industrie travailler sur
les enjeux de terre commerciale dernière
chose
il y a l'empilement des normes
présidents barbarie
il y a le coup sur la tête et la
démoralisation aussi qu'entraîne
des contrôles successifs pour ne pas
dire qu'on commit
on a aujourd'hui des entreprises qui à
deux ou trois mois près enchaînent les
contrôles alors ça joue sur l'activité
de la boîte ça joue beaucoup sur le
moral de l'entrepreneur
et ça joue
parce que tout se tient ça joue sur les
cessation volontaires d'activité
qui augmente
parce qu'à un moment on a pu en vie tu
crées de la valeur tu crées de l'emploi
tu donnes ta vie tu bosses le samedi le
dimanche tu dors pas les insomnies les
comptes dans la tête les machins et un
moment tu dis stop
je réfléchis et je vais me battre
pour essayer de proposer donc de mettre
en œuvre
l'idée d'un contrôle unique pour les
petites entreprises les entreprises de
petites tailles
et pas de contrôle on sédimentation
parce que un contrôle fiscal un contrôle
social qui s'enchaînent à moins de 6
mois sur une TPE de 7 salariés
il peut être létal
parce que la boîte doit fournir les
réponses les gars se mettent à répondre
aux inspecteurs et donc on produit pas
on vend moins on développe pas bon donc
je suis en train de travailler et
j'aurais sûrement besoin de votre
soutien
pour parvenir à faire en sorte que pour
les très petites entreprises qui
fonctionnent avec très peu de TP c'est
contrôle qui représentent un travail
supplémentaire important et donc un
manque à gagner important
soit
convergent et unique et en fait comme
mon conseiller
le me le disait d'ailleurs il y a pas
longtemps et ça reboucle un peu les
changes qu'on a ce matin
s'il y a pas trop de normes et qu'elles
sont pas trop lourdes il y a pas de
raison qu'on puisse pas avoir un
contrôle unique
mais si les normes sont trop lourdes ou
trop complexes et qu'on peut pas faire
contre l'unique alors dites moi
lesquelles et donc c'est intéressant
qu'on ça permet aussi de d'évaluer un
peu la nécessité la portée de la norme
parce que si on me dit que sur une TPE 4
ou 7 salariés il y a beaucoup trop de
normes pour un contrôle unique alors là
ce sera un sujet
mais c'est un dossier sur lequel je
travaille et sur lequel je ferai des
propositions dans les mois qui viennent
si je peux juste une petite viande
abondissante
ceci explique cela madame la ministre
vous disiez tout à l'heure les chefs
d'entreprise ils vont jamais aux impôts
à l'URSSAF chercher de l'aide mais
évidemment parce que 9 fois sur 10 ça se
passe mal donc si on arrive sur un
contrôle unique ça peut être intéressant
mais ne serait-ce que d'avoir enfin on y
revient sur des entreprises de toutes
petites tailles de moins de 10
qui sont quand même une bonne majorité
de boîtes
c'est aussi une question de psychologie
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on rappelle
que dans la politique au sens noble il
faut qu'on considère la psychologie
avoir un seul être humain qui répond à
tes questions sociales fiscales c'est
quand même beaucoup moins anxiogène que
d'en avoir 12
je veux pas relancer le débat merci de
de
vous explications et des propositions
que vous formulez simplement puisque
vous parlez psychologie je suis pas sûr
que mettre tout le monde derrière des
écrans s'asseoir le meilleur moyen de
faciliter la psychologie et la
compréhension c'est pas là où je voulais
en venir
tout à l'heure mon collègue a fait des
comparaisons et comparaisons des
parisons moi je pourrais simplement
souhaiter que l'INPI puisse adapter ses
besoins en partenaire en personnel ou en
collaborateur comme a pu le faire de
Tony parce que doctolib c'est de 2800
salariés donc il faut faire attention
mais moi je veux bien sénateur mais si
vous voulez qu'on embauche autant que
ces salariés que chez doctolib il va y
avoir des syncopes en PLF je dis
comparaison n'est pas raison voilà
et je souhaiterais que mais je suis
réaliste aussi cela dit mon collègue a
souvent cité ce qui se passait en Europe
du Nord et donc vous avez parlé d'état
d'esprit et moi je pense qu'il faut
s'interroger là-dessus la différence
entre sur ces sujets là notamment entre
ce que fait l'Europe du Nord et ce que
ne fait pas l'Europe du Sud et je
reviens à ma première question parce que
il me semble que par le passé il les
rapports il y a même eu un secrétaire
d'État Thierry Manon qui a fait des
propositions et tout ce qu'on fait il
faut s'interroger pourquoi en France il
y a un obstacle pour aller vers une
autorité indépendante sur ces aspects de
normes et sur ces
sur ces aspects de l'étude d'impact il
faut arriver à s'interroger là-dessus
puisque
il me semble que il y a eu plusieurs
propositions il y a eu un secrétaire
d'État qui a fait aussi les propositions
il le Sénat fait des rapports et ça se
met pas en place et quand on se rend
compte on dit bah il faudrait un moment
un moment faut lever les faut lever les
les questions les obstacles
je
j'entends bien sénateur de village
l'autorité indépendante elle existe et
elle était fissure pour les
collectivités la question de son champ
peut être regardé
moi je crois plus enfin d'ailleurs ça
n'est pas antinomique mais je crois
beaucoup
au réflexe obligatoire TPME dans tous
les textes normatifs
je crois beaucoup plus à
l'obligation entre guillemets qu'on
pourrait faire notre de mettre en place
un test PME sur les projets de loi ou
propositions de loi alors je dis ça
maintenant il faut le l'écrire mais non
mais je crois beaucoup plus à la
ce que d'ailleurs je fais quand j'ai des
textes normatifs ou réglementaires une
sorte de collège informel ou je
ping-pong avec des chefs d'entreprise
au-delà des organisations
professionnelles qui évidemment je
ping-pong aussi qui permet d'affiner
d'améliorer la portée de la proposition
il faudrait qu'on puisse systématiser ça
au même titre d'ailleurs qu'on
systématise de plus en plus la
considération de l'impact sur la terre
la considération de l'impact écologique
la considération dans chaque texte de
loi je pense qu'il faut considérer
les petites entreprises
alors une dernière intervention de notre
collègue canevé sur un sujet d'actualité
merci à Monsieur le Président Madame
minet chers collègues une observation
une interrogation une observation pour
revenir sans réouvrir le débat sur ce
que Gilbert Luc de Vinas évoquait tout à
l'heure le guichet unique et nous avions
effectivement prévenu dès l'année
dernière qu'il y aurait des difficultés
mais l'avantage du dispositif c'est
qu'il fait disparaître 50 CERFA faut
jamais l'oublier et que remplace 50
CERFA par une démarche donc là on est
dans la simplification effectivement
concrète dès que ça marche alors une
interrogation quand même sur le grand
débat actuel sur la question des
chaudières au gaz parce que il y a toute
une filière qui est composée de PME
d'entreprises artisanale dans le domaine
de l'installation du chauffage mais une
filière économique performante dans
notre pays qui fabrique des chaudières
gaz qui s'interrogent parce que
l'ambition du électrique risque de nous
mettre dans la panade je veux dire par
là qu'on n'est pas capable de produire
toute l'électricité dont on aura besoin
demain et on engage dès à présent un
débat qui risque de fragiliser de
beaucoup d'entreprises dans notre et ce
sont des PME j'en ai visité une lundi
900 personnes à Morlaix il y en a une
autre à côté 200 personnes
dans le Finistère
et donc on peut être inquiet
effectivement parce qu'on a là une
filière performante qui fabrique en
France et on veut s'orienter vers une
filière de production de pompe à chaleur
dont on sait que les composants viennent
quasi exclusivement de
d'Asie ça veut dire que d'un côté on va
déséquilibrer la balance commerciale
française alors qu'on a une balance
commerciale qui est améliorée par la
production qu'on est capable de faire
donc je voulais vous rendre attentive
là-dessus et on voit bien que il y a des
questions de normes que l'on veut
instituer au nom de belles idées de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
mais la réalité économique doit aussi
être prise en compte sur ce qui se passe
sur le terrain et dans ces cas là il
faut que les ministères économiques
soient également saisis du sujet pour
éviter que l'on aille dans la difficulté
comment le chauffagiste va-t-il qui est
qui a des compétences pour installer des
chaudières va-t-il pouvoir installer des
pompes à chaleur enfin bon et va-t-on
pouvoir en produire suffisamment donc il
y a tout un tas d'interrogations qui
sont posés sur cette nouvelle norme qui
semble c'est ce qui c'est
si je peux me permettre surtout qu'on
pousse à la production de gaz vert
et on va pas s'en servir on arrête
je suis bien plus compétente enfin non
je suis bien moins mauvaise on va dire
sur les entreprises que sur le gaz donc
cher
sénateur d'abord j'ai bien entendu ce
que vous avez dit on vous écoutant je me
disais
que vous avez raison c'est un sujet sur
lequel les ministère économique doivent
être vigilants
il y a
c'est transition à long terme qui
suppose une évolution des compétences
une évolution des entreprises qui sont
qui sont des sujets
complexes je pense aussi
je vois très bien je vais vous raconter
ma vie parce que comme mon mari n'est
pas breton contrairement à moi qui suis
d'origine bretonne vous le savez
je vois très bien parce que j'ai en tête
la PM enfin même la TPE en Haute-Saône à
gré qui a installé une
Haute-Saône c'est qui la Haute-Saône et
ben voilà et bah oui je savais qu'on
allait se retrouver moi je suis très
souvent à gré à ôter au trailer vous
savez tout se sait en haut de Saône ou
mon beau-père pour tout vous dire a fait
installer
une pompe à granules à bois donc j'ai
vécu l'épopée avec lui j'ai parlé avec
l'artisan
qui ma cartonné
sur les ZF sur le visage bon
donc je vois bien
j'ai pas la réponse mais je prends le
point après il y a des c'est un débat
que j'avais eu au Sénat d'ailleurs grâce
à vous où j'étais pas du tout qualifié
mais j'étais bien accompagné mais ça m'a
permis d'apprendre notamment sur les
garages automobiles et la transition à
l'aune de l'évolution des véhicules vers
des véhicules de thermique à électrique
voilà je vais pas à vous vous apprendre
qu'il y a aussi dans ces évolutions
parfois des
des opportunités pour les entreprises je
pense au rétrofit par exemple
je pense que c'est une activité
complémentaire assez rémunératrice sur
lesquels nous garages devraient se
positionner aujourd'hui comment l'État
accompagne comment l'État voilà une fois
que j'ai dit ça j'ai pas changé le
garagiste à gré il fait toujours pas du
retrofit
mais je pense qu'il y a là un sujet de
feuilles de route et d'accompagnement
des petits acteurs économiques et je
suis d'accord avec vous ce sont parfois
des sous couverts de bonnes intentions
sincères et d'objectif plutôt louable il
faut qu'on soit vigilant aussi sur nos
importations et notre balance
commerciale mais vous faites bien de me
rappeler ce sujet sénateur canev
madame la ministre merci je me revient
de conclure parce qu'on a des
obligations et dans l'hémicycle on
continue la discussion avec justice
merci pour ces échanges très riches
chacun d'entre vous et réponse qui
alimentent nos réflexions bien sûr nous
ne manquerons pas de vous remettre le
rapport et vous le présenter peut-être
on trouvera une occasion
dès qu'il aura été examiné le 15 juin
prochain donc on est dans l'actualité
pour mes collègues nous nous
retrouverons le 21 juin à 8h pour la
prochaine édition de la parole aux
entrepreneurs la lancer une série de
réunion ainsi où on reçoit des chefs
d'entreprises marquants et nous
recevrons Bruno Bouygues
qui est la tête d'une ETI mayonnaise
véhicule en plan mondial le savoir-faire
français dans les machines outils
automobilistes
exception intéressante et par ailleurs
le jeudi 29 juin à 8h30 nous examinons
le rapport formation compétences à
tractivite le travail du moment sur
notre délégation donc merci aux uns aux
autres merci beaucoup madame la ministre
de votre simplicité à échanger avec nous
et nous la pression et on est évidemment
on a eu l'occasion de parler avec le
collaborateurs très largement et il y a
plein de sujets qui nous intéressera de
pouvoir sur lesquels il sera intéressant
de revenir on a noté tout ça donc on
aura plein d'autres
occasions merci à chacun très bonne
journée merci à vous c'est Nathan
barbarie vous dire juste une chose je
déteste que vous le découvririez dans
les presse alors que vous m'avez en face
un je vais annoncer dans les jours qui
viennent les premiers lauréats du fond
commerce rural j'en avais parlé la
dernière fois c'est assez simple et
voyez c'est c'est une méthode que
j'essaye d'appliquer c'est vrai que
c'est pas Bercy depuis Paris qui a
choisi des projets de rénovation ou de
réhabilitation de commerce dans la
ruralité ce sont les préfectures les
sous-préfets et nous avons validé
ensuite qui ont fait une première
sélection de 80 projets qui vont être
financés qui vont se déployer dès cet
été notamment en Haute-Saône ce qui m'a
permis de réveiller la Côte d'Or qui m'a
pas envoyé deux dossiers
c'est vraiment très simple et pour le
coup j'ai même mis en place une brique
de 5000 euros pour accompagner les
porteurs de projets qui n'ont pas
d'ingénierie qui ne savent pas faire un
dossier il reste de l'argent il reste de
la place pour des lauréats c'est simple
de candidater
n'hésitez pas à solliciter les acteurs
autour de vous et à le faire savoir
première vague annoncée là dans les
jours qui viennent 80 L'Oréal
deuxièmement
vous m'entendrez fin juin début juillet
parler mais je vous en ai dit un mot de
en gros l'article 11 que je porte dans
réindus verts autour de la rénovation
des friches et des zones commerciales
j'ai obtenu un budget l'an passé pour
faire des projets pilotes des
expérimentations autour de quatre ou
cinq rénovation reconversion de zone
commerciale l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt pour les les zones qui
souhaiteraient se porter candidates sera
lancée fin juin début juillet si vous
avez dans vos circonscriptions dans vos
communes ou autour de vous des zones qui
pourraient faire l'objet de ces
expérimentations et de ses projets
pilotes n'hésitez pas ça fera l'objet de
de d'une bonne partie de mon actualité
cet été voilà commerce rural et zone
commerciale pour le reste on continue je
vous le redis je suis totalement
disponible
ainsi que mes équipes
pour traiter parce que je sais qu'il y
en a encore et j'en traite encore tous
les jours des dossiers de TPE en
difficulté dans le cadre de leur facture
d'énergie donc n'hésitez jamais
parfois on appelle et la bonne nouvelle
c'est que c'est pas du tout un problème
d'énergie c'est un autre problème mais
dans le doute on est là pour ça merci
merci bonne journée à tous